believe it or not this month marks three
years since the World Health
Organization declared covid-19 a
pandemic and while cases and
hospitalizations are down the disease is
still part of the everyday lives of
Americans who are battling long covet
editor at large for public health at
Kaiser health news and CBS News medical
contributor Dr Celine gownder met a
patient whose life changed Forever After
Her diagnosis Dr gounder joined her at a
post covet Clinic to learn about the new
ways that doctors are helping patients
regain some normalcy
almost there for Trevor Taylor most
mornings start off like this one small
step at a time I'm finishing strong huh
yeah that's kind of strong it's been an
uphill battle for the 57 year old who
told us Her cobit diagnosis in January
2021 nearly killed her it was scary
because I remember my eyes being open
but everything was black I remember
the late that the nurse saying to me you
have to fight the person next to you is
dying and if you don't you're going to
be in this body bag you've got to fight
Taylor wasn't vaccinated at the time she
was rushed to the hospital on the same
day that she was scheduled to get her
first dose of the covid vaccine
since then she's been out of work and
instead of driving to the hospital to
her old job as an administrator she
makes the trip multiple times a week for
physical therapy go for two minute
intervals if you can and then just take
a break the timer will stop all right I
do my therapy I come home I can't move
off the couch so for me I'm up and down
like a roller coaster one minute I
breathe good next minute I don't and
then when I have a lot of activity for a
day I can be down for 48 hours cannot
get out the bed so the whole way up
Taylor's become one of millions of
Americans to experience long covid her
case so severe that she relies on oxygen
to get around there you go right here my
love you did it home stretch look at you
for two years now she's been visiting
nyu's post covet CARE program it's come
my throat clear where she and one
thousand other patients are treated by
pulmonologists like Dr Rainey condos
they have what we call symptoms that are
associated with their covet infection
but are now lingering longer and so long
covet it is a major problem if you think
of the fact that about 25 percent of
patients may end up with long covet and
if you're talking about millions and
millions of patients you can imagine
that that's a large number patients with
long covet commonly experience symptoms
like fatigue brain fog shortness of
breath and chest pain now let's compare
Treva to other patients with long covid
how is she similar different from some
of the other patients so she's fairly
representative of the patients with
severe covid that we saw pre-vaccination
during the early days of the pandemic
these other patients with long covet
didn't have severe covet they had a cold
and the cold got better and then a few
months later they can't get out of bed
most of the long Covey patients that
we're seeing are those that were healthy
and now have lingering symptoms hush
stop don't stop keep going you got this
you got this almost there one way to
monitor those symptoms is through
breathing tests which Taylor receives
every six weeks
while exhausting the tool measures her
lung function and tracks her improvement
over time easy relax in what ways does
being a patient in a program like this
help patients heal many of these
patients were going to their primary
care doctors and their Primary Care
directors were telling them they were
crazy and that there was nothing wrong
with them and they should just go home
and forget it and they felt very unheard
and I think what we're trying to do is
provide a place for them to be heard hi
yes I need to reorder oxygen for myself
please thank you for every question I'm
requesting four tanks two small Too Tall
Trevor what would you like people to
know about long covid I would like for
people to understand that
first lawn covet is very real it's not
something that's in your head it's not
an imagination trust me I would do
anything not to be like this every day
getting up is a fight every day to
breathe is a fight but it's worth the
fight because I love people and people
give me energy and as long as I can show
a fight
I know that there's a chance
Taylor is in the process of being
evaluated for a possible lung transplant
a clear reminder of the long-term
effects of severe covid the good news
for so many other patients is that covid
vaccination reduces the risk of getting
long covid by at least half according to
a study in the Journal of the American
Medical Association last week yeah and
as you point out in your piece she was
that close to getting the vaccine before
she was diagnosed right this was before
this is when vaccines were first coming
out right in January 2021 so she's a
hospital administrator she has her
appointment and she gets coveted just a
couple days before her first shot if you
do get long covet is it forever coveted
or will it you eventually be kind of
cured and normal again whatever your
life was before well in her case she had
such severe lung damage I mean that's
why they're looking at giving her a lung
transplant
um so that's not a curable condition
that's permanent organ damage in general
can people who have long cover though
expect to recover maybe some people are
getting better with their symptoms over
time and we are looking at cures there's
a study right now looking at Pax lovid
the medication you use during a covet
infection to see if it might also help
all right Dr Celine gounder and vlad's
daughter don't you think she has one of
the prettiest names you've ever heard
yeah you did I agree